if you're a European politics
connoisseur like I selectively can be
then you've probably heard a little
something about Europe's move to the
right especially over the last few years
and you've probably also heard that it's
France that we need to be watching hey
guys I'm Sanne
this is aj+ and today we're going to
look at Europe's move to the right
Frances National Front party what they
want for France and how they just might
get it
[Music]
so before jumping into Frances far-right
I want to talk a little bit about how
and why you're shifted to the right a
shift that's been defined usually if not
always by three major points let's start
with the far-right euro scepticism which
means they're pretty wary it's not
completely anti European Union which
they blame for poor economic conditions
and for giving jobs to foreign workers
then there's the anti-immigrant
anti-refugee and anti Islam policies and
campaigns that have become central to
far-right platforms and finally being
anti all those things is how these
groups position themselves as populist
in their populism far-right groups claim
to the anti-establishment and represent
the voices and interest of everyday
people unless those people are
immigrants foreign workers refugees and
Muslims and Europe's refugee crisis has
been helpful for their cause becoming a
sort of political plotter in 2015 alone
over 1 million refugees and migrants
made their way into Europe mostly from
Syria Afghanistan and Iraq and as German
Chancellor Angela Merkel will tell you
welcoming over 1 million refugees into
your country doesn't mean they'll remain
welcomed in 2015 Chancellor Merkel made
headlines even becoming TIME's Person of
the Year
by setting the example for how Europe
should respond to the refugee crisis she
was applauded and heralded as a strong
leader but since then many Germans have
turned away from Merkel's welcome and
towards far-right anti-immigrant groups
like Savita and the alternative for
Germany party Paris by the way the
interesting thing about the alternative
for Germany party it started off as an
anti euro currency protest movement in
2013 and eventually involved into a
full-scale political party with an
anti-immigrant anti Islam platform in
2015 in fact on their platform they
explicitly state that there's no room
for Islam in Germany and that platform
seems to resonate with a lot of voters
in the March 2016 German state elections
alternative for Germany won almost 25
percent of the votes
it now has parliamentary seats in ten of
Germany's 16 states one of the other big
examples of the far-right making strides
in Europe is that of the United Kingdom
Independence Party which also utilized
anti-immigrant rhetoric and was
successful in convincing citizens to
vote in favour of leaving the European
Union then there's a Sweden Democrats
party which distance itself from its
white supremacist roots and in 2014 149
of 349 available parliamentary seats
that's 13% and that's impressive for a
party that had just 2.9 percent of the
votes in 2005 and of course there's
Greece is actually neo-fascist Golden
Dawn party which for the first time in
history got into the parliament in the
2012 elections with 18 seats and again
in 2016 winning the same number it's
currently the third largest party in
Greece a country which in 2015 had an
unemployment rate of almost 26% and is
still in some major major debt so yeah
the move to the right in Europe is
happening and it's happening quickly and
it's happening at the voting system and
the examples I just went through are
probably the biggest instances of how
and why the anti-immigrant anti-eu
far-right is coming into a European
mainstream but it's France that has
everyone on their toes especially since
it's a founding member of the EU Frances
far-right nationalist party is a
National Front and it was founded in
1972 by jean-marie Le Pen and brought
together former members of France's
Vichy regime self-described fascist
anti-immigrant nationalist and others of
a similar feather lapel was known for
his extreme right-wing perspectives and
positions as well as being the party to
perpetual presidential candidate lepen
also often made comments sympathetic to
the Nazis like for instance saying that
the Nazi occupation of France wasn't
really all that inhumane or that Jews
around the world or that races are in
equal he even actually at one point was
convicted of being a Holocaust denier as
a result of calling Nazi gas chambers
just a detail in the history of world
war ii the party itself stood for
nationalism limited immigration and
isolationism under John Murray Lopez the
party
variants varying levels of success and
peaked in 2002 when Lipan came in second
in the first round of voting but would
go on to lose to Joshua
now that loss was heavy for the National
Front and the party basically faded away
but in 2011 John marine lepen resigned
as the head of the party and his
daughter marine lepen took over and as
everyone characterizes it even today she
brought the party to the forefront of
French politics almost overnight marine
lipet immediately began reforming the
party she wanted to distance the
National Front from its path as much as
possible so she denounced anti-semitism
and xenophobia and while the party would
overturn the marriage equality law she's
included openly gay advisors all around
her which is huge for a party whose
founder once famously said that it had
quote no Queen's lahpet is also
pro-choice sees the state as critical in
providing social services to citizens
and in perhaps one of her biggest
reforms to the party she recruited
younger politicians but while that seems
like a big departure from the party of
her father
most things which are critical to the
National Front historically haven't
really changed all that much because
here is what the National Front
ultimately want there are not huge fans
of the EU though leaving it would be
difficult without parliamentary support
the front wants to restrict immigration
by slashing it by 80% lepen also wants
to enforce a special tax on foreign
workers job contracts restrict the
French citizenship process and even
restrict government services to
immigrants lepen speaks at length at her
rallies about cultural values or
preservation civilizational clashes and
bringing back jobs to french workers and
in 2015 she even got in hot water for
comparing French Muslims praying in the
streets to the Nazi occupation of France
but here's the thing in 2016 and 2017
marine lepen National Front has been
sweeping across voters that probably
wouldn't have supported the old front
her anti Islam anti-immigrant platform
especially has made the front appealing
to a lot of voters take for example how
the front has 40% support amongst voters
ages 18 to 24 a voting bloc that
traditionally votes left
despite the incredible surge in support
for marine lepen
front in the run-up to the 2017 French
elections many experts and pollsters
don't think lapel will be able to claim
the French presidency but given how
far-right populist campaigns and talking
points have gotten in the UK in the
United States and in other parts of
Europe
maybe marine lepen will make for another
surprise hey guys I hope you enjoyed the
video I was actually pretty surprised as
to how popular the National Front is
with voters especially young voters like
what so what do you think do you think
lepen can take it let us know in the
comments and don't forget to like share
and subscribe